yeah for it you join Australia to meet another
professional from another sport is always fun
get to know a little bit about their Sports so
you get laces out like some middle finger bosss
you drop it and you just try to H like sweet spot
fo there nice yep it's always fun to get out of
your comfort zone a little bit and learn about
the things I know there's a local league and
stuff here and um there's definitely people are
interested in NHL and this is kind of an amazing
thing to bring I guess that exposure of people
that have been following it for a long time people
that will start following in the future with NHL
coming down under it was great to be out here
and potentially once in a lifetime experience and
that's what's really fun about this trip it's just
day after day you get to experience new things
sick man yeah than thanks brother nice me [Music]
you